et après à partir de décembre on a eu 20
% du chiffre d'affaires ce qui est
important c'est pourquoi la société
le gérant qui est travaillé nos salariés
n'a pas des ti la mairie a droit au rsa
c'est ça donc c'est quand même
catastrophique on nous sommes en train
de peser pendant 14 mois là c'est un
truc de fou
christophe ah ben moi que j'ai la chance
j'avais un peu des économies qui m'aide
ouais voilà tout simplement a pensé un
moment fermé tu t'es dit c'est moi où je
vais plus voir ouvrir ben on est sur le
point de tout perdre sans tout aimé
qu'on nous dise parce que le problème
c'est qu'on a joué avec nous pendant
pendant 14 mois c'est à dire que au
départ on nous dit on vous ferme trois
semaines donc on l'a dit trois semaines
c'est pas grave on va faire un coup de
fraîcheur mais un coup de peinture tout
ça on se prépare après on nous a dit
vous allez ouvrir aux autres en kz2 au
30 juin
donc pour le pour le match puis on s'est
préparé on a tout nettoyé tout la
discothèque de fond en comble et puis
tous les trois mois on nous a repoussé
donc on a aucune perspective annuelle
jouer avec notamment les seuls qui
n'avait jamais ouvert
j'avais ouvert mais on a joué avec nous
parce qu'ils aient tous les trois mois à
dire vous allez ouvrir bientôt bientôt
est ici leverdez j'aimerais bien savoir
s'il est pour les mariages web en
battant mariage comment ils vont faire
un mille personnes par rapport à
layrisse potec la raison ils vont pas
danser ils vont pas santé va demander au
roi du dancefloor depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire tout le monde s'en fout
des boîtes de nuit qui sont restés à un
lieu de débauche c'est vrai il sert à
rien alors que c'est pas vrai déjà c'est
un lieu de rencontres et des peines un
lien social pour plein de gens et puis
c'est un acteur très important dans
l'économie française contrairement à ce
que croient qu'on peut croire vous
n'êtes pas si minoritaire que soit sa
regarder les chiffres vous avez deux
mille boîtes de nuit en france 1
milliard d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
100 mille salariés au sens large dans le
monde de la nuit et ça fait en plus
gagner de l'argent aux artistes donc il
faut les ouvrir et maintenant ça alors
je t'apprécie de ge au moins la moitié
vidéo qui est en duplex
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
laissez-moi précision 8h par ce à quoi
je pense je pensais même phrase de pegi
pegi
j'ai toujours dit ce que l'on voit mais
plus difficile il faut voir ce que l'on
voit c'est pas d'afflelou c'est pourquoi
je dis ça en fait parce que qu'est ce
qu'on voit là oui on voit des gens qui
ont été maltraités pendant un an on voit
quand je dis depuis le début de cette
affaire que ça va mal finir
et qu'en fait il ya un mépris profond du
peuple français
est-ce que c'est pas d'ailleurs mais
s'ils en sont là nous sommes nous sommes
sont deux mecs ans et ya pire
oui c'est que maintenant pour réouvrir
on va les transformer en policier
sanitaires on va leur demander d'avoir
effectivement un test négatif ici ou un
vaccin là mais quel vaccin à 13,1 et k s
qui vont être effectivement responsable
si du variant sud africain et vérifier à
quelle variante donc à un moment donné
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
est-ce qu'on veut reprendre une vie
normale ou est-ce qu'on veut abandonner
considérer que l'on vit au rythme et
finalement degré de ce virus et qu'on
est dans un monde d'après dans lequel la
notion de liberté a été totalement
abolis
[Applaudissements]